to talk about what I think is the worst
graphic novel of all time it's Frank
Miller it's holy terror now I'm a huge
French Miller fine I absolutely love
Dark Knight Returns it's my favorite
Batman graphic novel
I got posters and [ __ ] at it and I think
that a perfectly captures the character
updates that puts them in a modern
setting however as of late Frank Miller
has went completely mental delight is
just putting out [ __ ] constantly
all-star Batman and Robin is hilarious
but terrible don't make strikes again
hilarious absolutely terrible and Holy
Terror is just a complete example of how
much the guy had messed up they should
call it holy terrible they should call
it holy error on Frank's part in 2006 he
announced that he'd be working on Batman
Holy Terror
which was a book that was gonna kind of
deal with al-qaeda he famously said
Superman punch pepper
Captain America punched Hitler it's what
these characters do and he's put an
updated spin on it with Batman they say
though they've been around for eight
years obviously they're not going to
publish something that's massively
racist towards a religious group so the
knocked on the head but Frank Miller
still went ahead with it
and we ended up a holy terror it still
is a Batman story I don't care what
Frank Miller says all the characters are
exactly the same as a Batman story and
it's just an excuse to sort
which I can't really get annoyed at
because some of my favorite books like
nemesis and superior by markeloff are
also sort of passages of famous
characters so when it's done well it's
done well it isn't good well it opens on
the quote if you meet the infidel kill
the infidel by Mohammed I later found
out this isn't even a quote and that
Craig Miller this made it look like and
it's clear this booth wants to give you
an excuse to hate Muslims from the off
and instantly struck me is really left
field and a shallow way to open the
story the best does in anything are
always written with death and complexity
and you can sort of see things from
their side in this they have absolutely
no debt to them Mela doesn't try and
kind of understand what drives someone
to be a terrorist he doesn't take any
blame for what America have done to
Middle Eastern countries
he just portrays them as mindless
villains who will murder anyone it has
one of the worst openings I've ever seen
the clip so bad it's even harder like
flick through it so it just opens on
please stop it and it's just people
going test huff huff
I mean it goes on for a while where the
only thing that anyone says is up and
it's Mela is laziest this was a guy who
knocked out yeah one and the Dark Knight
Returns within a really short time
period and nowadays you can't even do
Dog Night part three in less than
and it means overseen by someone else I
got really lazy and this is a prime
example of it so as the fixer chases
Catwoman she's not given a name she's
Pat woman across the rooftop will then
hit with this explosion and it's a mixed
one of those most Awkward sex scenes
I've ever seen in comics you just have
pages like this where it's just faces
and then it turns into a double spread
of just boxes eventually these boxes get
smaller and smaller and then nothing get
what it's meant to me and I get it's
meant to symbolize all the people that
I've died in there's such a big number
but it's just such a lazy way to do it
there's a great book that came out
recently by DC called love is love which
looks at the Florida shooting of a gay
club and every page has a story on it
and on an entire page got Commissioner
Gordon you also have tires of political
figures it's just pictures of them
though I always think that the best
satire comes across from what they say
and the fact that these characters don't
say anything it's very much style over
substance look at it you go that's a
good drawing of Barack Obama but that's
it it's not satire and anything he says
whenever you satire something the
look-alike aspect of it is the one thing
not necessary it's more to do with what
they say and how they accent really
portrays them they look like things just
there for you to connect with you it is
and they don't actually say anything it
just has no depth to it the characters
say god damn the record damn second
because it's only god damn word Frank
Miller knows nothing depict any god damn
promotion how's stuff in it like if my
record
for those 72 virgins as they kill a
terrorist and I never thought that book
that you can read it 20 minutes would be
solved by he pasted ends up were like a
terrorist plot where you can't really
tell what's going on and there's these
silhouettes with characters talking I
don't know how you met me tell who is
who could be honest just again just
laziness and it just becomes a mush and
plural colors and I just hated it and it
made me want to go on my own
Isis book burning campaign with some of
my favorite Frank Miller fiction it
works really well as a coffee coaster
which i think is a good point that I
should bring up but other than that
there's not much air that warrants you
picking it up
I wouldn't wish it on my worst enemy I
wouldn't wish it on the people who
orchestrated 9/11 Ben Lord and probably
read this group in this story [ __ ] it
[ __ ] [ __ ] by from start to finish it
doesn't even fit on my boots jump
correctly like look at that it's it's
poking out like oh that's it I can't
even word is a book it doesn't even
function as a group I don't know where
Frank Miller was switched out with this
bizarro version of himself but this is
just an absolute disaster like this is a
bigger disaster any I shouldn't say that
but it's really bad one of the main
positives to take from it though is it's
so bad it'll probably never get into the
printing which means that it might be
worth a bit of money in a couple years
massively racist every Muslim and it's
painted out to be a villain even the
heroes are really one-dimensional Frank
Miller only seems to be able to write
Carrie Kelly so every female in every
is Carrie Kelly and Bruce Wayne 2050 and
every character that right is exactly
the same and I'm just I'm sick of the
life I can't defend him anymore after
this crap so overall I give it a two out
of ten what did you think about mine
Holy Terror comment below and let me
know and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]